president from six the DOJ on the FBI
left his cry foul and did the Pope just
actually shift Catholic policy on
homosexuality we'll talk about all of it
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
oh yes and I'm so happy to be back I had
a wonderful three-day weekend because it
was the Jewish holiday of Shavuot which
meant that I was barred from electronics
and couldn't travel and all that which
meant I got to spend time with my family
and read which are my two favorite
things in the world so I'm in a very
good mood and then I checked the news
last night and I'm in less of a good
mood so we'll talk about why I'm in less
good after checking all of the news last
night I do want to remind everybody by
the way that we do have upcoming events
happening in Dallas and Phoenix those
are coming up in August and you can go
to Daley wired.com slash events if you
want to get tickets for that we're
nearly sold out I believe in both places
where we're approaching sellout
proportions certainly in both places
right now it's only been open to the
general public for a couple of days here
so you got a rush to get those tickets
in right now Dallas and Phoenix coming
up in August check it out daily wire.com
slash events also I want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at Birch gold so
right now the economy is doing really
well the dollar is quite strong but that
means in some cases that the only place
to go is down which is one of the
reasons that you least want to hedge
your bets with some precious metals I'm
not saying take all your money out of
the stock market and start buying gold
and storing it in your attic what I am
saying is that if you haven't hedged any
of your precious metals you're making
somewhat of a mistake and this is why
you should talk to my friends over at
Birch gold group they have a
long-standing track record of continued
success with thousands of satisfied
clients countless five-star reviews and
an A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau right now you can contact Birch
gold to request a free information kit
on physical precious metals the
comprehensive 16 page kit reveals how
gold and silver can protect your savings
how you can legally move your IRA or
401k out of stocks and bonds and into a
precious metals IRA if so you choose to
get that no-cost no-obligation kit all
you have to do is go to birchgold.com
slash Ben that is birchgold.com
slash men again you owe it to yourself
to have at least a little bit of your
money in precious metals to protect
against inflation to protect against all
the sorts of volatility in the market to
protect against foreign policy shocks
and all the rest birchgold.com slash Ben
gets you your information once you've
asked all your information and you've
gotten all of your information then you
can think about investing go to
birchgold.com slash Ben those are the
folks that I trust all righty so the big
news of course is this blow-up between
President Trump and the FBI so President
Trump over the weekend tweeted out that
the FBI had been surveilling his
campaign during the campaign based on
stories that broke late last week from
the New York Times that there were
an informant who'd been working within
the Trump campaign to bring information
about supposed collusion between members
of the Trump campaign and Russia and
Trump pointed back to his tweet early in
2016 in which he said that he was
wiretapped at Trump Tower now Trump
himself was not wired tapped at Trump
Tower however he did allege that he was
surveilled during the campaign it's not
clear that Trump personally was
surveilled during the campaign but there
were members of his campaign who are
surveilled during the campaign so the
reason that I want to clarify all of
this is because what you're hearing from
both left and right I think are
over-broad versions of the stories that
are that are actually worth telling so
from the right way you're hearing is
there was a deep conspiracy a deep state
conspiracy to get President Trump from
the point when it wasn't even clear he
was gonna be the nominee all the way
back in March 2016 the FBI was going
after Trump's campaign trying to sink
him from the inside can we'll go through
the evidence for that and demonstrate
what's true about that and what is not
sure about that
well you're hearing from the left is
Trump obviously colluded with Russia the
members of the Trump team are in bed
with Vladimir Putin and Putin was
actually calling the shots from the
Kremlin and he was deciding how exactly
Trump should campaign he was deciding
how the campaign would go so everything
was totally aboveboard by the FBI okay
so we're gonna go through all of the
evidence here and we're gonna discuss
what is real and what is not here is
what happened over the last 24 hours so
according to the New York Times in White
House chief of staff Ash's Washington
Post rather White House chief of staff
John Kelly plans to convene a meeting
between top law enforcement and
intelligence officials and GOP national
leaders to quote-unquote review highly
classified and other information the
lawmakers have requested about the FBI's
use of a confidential source to aid an
investigation of the Trump campaign a
White House spokeswoman said Monday
President Trump met for an hour Monday
with Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein FBI director Christopher ray
and Director of National Intelligence
Stan Coates the meeting came a day after
the DOJ asked its Inspector General to
investigate Trump's claim that his
campaign may have been infiltrated by
the FBI source for political purposes
and amid continued demands from GOP
lawmakers that the department produced
materials on the person White House
press secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders
said that in a meeting it was agreed the
White House chief of staff Kelly will
immediately set up a meeting with other
FBI DOJ and DNI together with
congressional leaders to review highly
classified and other information they
have requested the significance of that
was not immediately clear do
leaders have fought vigorously against
revealing to Congress materials on the
source they say that if they reveal who
the informant was that will leak to the
press the press basically has already
come up with who the informant was it
has not been fully confirmed yet so I'm
not going to mention the name of the
informant on the show but it's pretty
obvious who this informant was through
basic google searches you can get the
person's name it was not clear whether
they back down from their position and
would not allow it would now allow GOP
leaders to look at the documents or
whether there would simply be a
follow-up meeting for more discussion so
according to Republicans there have been
two big boo-boos and these two big
boo-boos demonstrate ill-will toward the
Trump campaign and demonstrate that the
Obama run FBI was actually attempting to
get Trump all the way back during the
Republican primaries so these two
boo-boos supposedly were the use of an
informant to go after George papadopolis
and to go after Carter page two Trump
foreign policy aides Papadopoulos had
met in I believe April in London with a
Russian cutout who was a professor in
London who had close ties with the
Russians and who had suggested that the
Russian government could get information
about Hillary Clinton's emails to the
Trump campaign Papadopoulos had run that
up the chain nothing had happened
because of it but Papadopoulos obviously
we who's apparently bragging about it in
front of the Australian ambassador to
the Australian ambassador called the FBI
the FBI decided to put an informant on
Papadopoulos is sort of how the timeline
there goes the implication here by
Republicans is that all of that was
useless not only useless
counterproductive not only
counterproductive politically motivated
that if Papadopoulos had been working
for Hillary Clinton nobody would have
even attempted such a thing hey that is
claimed number one claim number two is
that the Carter page FISA warrant which
was gotten late in the years like
September 2016 that Carter page FISA
warrant was ill-gotten that it was
gotten on the basis of the seal dossier
now you recall the seal dossier I know
this all gets complicated but I'm trying
to break it down the steel dossier as
you recall was a was originally a
dossier funded by the Washington free
beacon that was supposed to uncover
Apple research about president Trump the
Washington free beacon was working
through a firm called fusion GPS before
Christopher Steele a British spy signed
on the Washington free beacon dropped
all this and they said we're not
interested in doing this anymore
and so the fusion GPS group went and got
Hillary Clinton's campaign to fund it at
that point Christopher Steele is a
British spy signed on and provided all
of this information about Trump some of
it surely
some of it likely false some of it may
be true about Trump and Russia okay and
Christopher Steele's dossier was
supposedly used as the basis for the
FISA warrants against Carter Paige and
O'Connor Paige have been again a
low-level foreign policy adviser to the
Trump campaign since 2013 Carter Paige
had been in the eye of the intelligence
community people in the intelligence
community were afraid that maybe he was
a Russian spy he'd been going around
basically soliciting money from the
Russians apparently allegedly and so
they looked at this and they said okay
well let's let's get a wiretap on Carter
Paige let's go out and let's get all the
information on Carter Paige the the
accusation being made by representative
Devon Nunez at the House Intelligence
Committee he's the chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee that the Carter
Paige FISA warrant was basically trumped
up by Democrats in order to get the
Trump campaign so there are two claims
two separate claims about two separate
people that say that the Trump campaign
was targeted and ill in ill-conceived
fashion in corrupt fashion one was the
FISA warrant on Carter page which comes
about later in 2016 and one is the
earlier use of an informant against
George papadopolis and maybe Carter page
as well at the time okay with all of
that in mind President Trump calls the
DOJ on the carpet and he says guys I
need you to investigate what is going on
with the FBI you need to tell me what's
going on were they in fact targeting me
now the New York Times of course has the
New York Times has suggested that even
by Trump going to his own DOJ and asking
for an investigation that this is
obstruction nonsense okay the President
of the United States has plenary power
over the executive branch the executive
branch includes the FBI and the DOJ if
the President of the United States wants
to meet with his DOJ and order them to
investigate something he certainly can
do that what he can't do maybe is tell
them what outcome to come up with an
investigation so he can actually tell
the DOJ to drop an investigation that is
within his legal power he can also fire
people from inside the DOJ could fire
James Comey at the FBI all of that is
within his legal power what could look
like obstruction of justice criminal
obstruction of justice is if President
Trump were to come forward and to say
something like I know that you're about
to find me guilty of obstruction or
you're about to indict me on obstruction
i order you to clear me on obstruction
instead right that he cannot do but
anything else he can pretty much do so
the New York Times is whining about this
Charlie Savage the New York Times says
when President Trump publicly demanded
that the DOJ open an investigation into
the
a scrutiny of his campaign contacts with
Russia he inched further toward
breaching an established constraint on
executive power the White House does not
make decisions about individual law
enforcement investigations okay
well yeah not so much it was pretty
obvious from the outset of the Hillary
investigation that Barack Obama was
never going to allow the DOJ to actually
prosecute Hillary Clinton he said that
he wasn't going to interfere Loretta
Lynch said she wasn't going to interfere
and then she was meeting on the tarmac
with Bill Clinton in the middle of the
investigation Barack Obama was going on
national television saying he didn't see
any evidence that Hillary ought to be
indicted none of this spoke to the
independence of the DOJ Eric Holder was
calling Barack Obama you know he was
saying he was Barack Obama's wingman
during his actual service as Attorney
General on the DOJ so the idea that the
DOJ is a completely independent agency
has no basis in law or fact nonetheless
the New York Times says that Trump is
doing something unprecedented
Rebecca Roy he is a professor at New
York law school who helped write a
coming scholarly article on the limits
of presidential control over the Justice
Department she says it's an incredible
historical moment mr. Trump's move is
the culmination of a lot of moments in
which he has chipped away at
prosecutorial independence but this is a
direct assault it is not a direct
assault there's nothing new about the
president calling the DOJ in and saying
I want you to investigate X Y or Z he is
allowed to do that as an executive
branch agency is not an independent
agency the US government does not have
independent agencies there are agencies
that are under the legislative auspices
there alleges they're there their
agencies that are the judicial auspices
and their agencies that are under the
executive auspices the DOJ is a
constitutional position filled by the
President of the United States he has
complete power over the DOJ nonetheless
the New York Times is very upset about
this they say almost since he took
office mr. Trump has battered his
Justice Department's independence
indirectly lamenting its failure to
reopen a criminal investigation of
Hillary Clinton that found no wrongdoing
and openly complaining that Attorney
General Jeff Sessions recused himself
from the Russia inquiry but he had also
acknowledged that as president I'm not
supposed to be involved with the Justice
Department as part of that pattern he
has also denied the account by James
Comey and FBI director he abruptly fired
that the president privately urged him
to drop an investigation into Michael
Flynn Trump's first national security
adviser now here it is important to
recognize a distinction right Trump is
not telling anybody to drop the Muller
investigation he's not telling rod Rosen
Stein to actually fire James Comey I
mean to actually fire Robert Muller he's
not telling anybody
shut down the SDN why investigation into
Michael Kohn he's saying open an
additional investigation into something
I find corrupt this is utterly and
completely within his power hey he is
allowed to do this there's no question
he is allowed to do this so it is not
obstruction for Trump to meet with his
own department of justice so that's
number one number two it's not
obstruction for Trump to actually order
the DOJ to investigate the FBI's 2016
conduct and this is not the same
investigation as I say is the Muller
investigation he's not interfering in
that he's not interfering in to the SDN
why investigation into Michael Kohn the
Southern District of New York
investigation into his personal attorney
Michael Kohn okay so for all the talk
about this is Trump muddying the waters
interfering doing something no okay all
of this is perfectly allowed now I will
tell you where I think that my feelings
about the the kind of conservative
narrative here are different than you
might hear from some other conservative
commentators but first I want to say
thanks to our sponsors over at filter by
so when's the last time you check the
filters in your central air system
I know sexy right you go home you kick
off your shoes and you're dreaming about
those filters in your central air system
well the reality is you haven't thought
about the filters in your central air
system for the last 15 years which means
you are now breathing gunk okay you have
not thought about those filters and when
you open up those filters you will see
that they are filled with dust and yuck
and that is why you need to go over to
filter by hey you're not only
aggravating your health you might
actually be destroying your HVAC system
leading to thousands of bucks and
repairs so stop procrastinating and
visit my friends over at filter by
America's leading provider of HVAC
filters for homes and small businesses
they carry over 600 different filter
sizes even custom ones all shipped for
free within 24 hours plus they are
manufactured right here in the United
States filter by offers a multitude of
em ERV options all the way up to
hospital grade check your system
specifications so you can pick the right
option maximize efficiency and elevate
the quality of the air that you breathe
you can set up auto delivery as well so
you don't have to think about air
filters ever again you never have to sit
up late at night thinking about your air
filters they just arrive at your house
plus you save 5% save money save time
and breathe better with filter by comm
we use it at the daily wire offices we
use it at the Shapiro household filter
by comm filter bu Y comm go check them
out filter by comm
make sure that the air that you are
breathing is clean okay so I'm there so
again it is within Trump's purview to
talk to the DOJ about this it's within
trumps purview to launch an
investigation
and in fact I'm not saying there's no
grounds to launch the investigation it's
possible there are grounds another
former Trump campaign aide named Michael
Caputo he came forward he said that
another informant approached me saying
that there was one the reports are
there's one informants that approached
the the approached Carter page and
George papadopolis
now they're saying there's a second
informant that approached Michael Caputo
during the campaign let me tell you
something that I know for a fact the
this informant this person that they
planted tried to plant into the campaign
and even into the administration if you
believe Axios he's not the only person
that came at the campaign and the FBI is
not the only Obama agency that came at
the campaign
I know because they came at me and I'm
looking for clearance to my attorney to
reveal this to the public this is just
the beginning okay so if it turns out
that pretty much everyone in the Trump
campaign whether or not they were
involved in suspicious contacts was
being targeted by informants then it
starts to look a lot more like the
conspiracy theory is true that the Obama
FBI was targeting the Trump campaign in
the very early stages Mike Pence is
saying that Trump is very grateful the
DOJ is looking into surveillance make
sense the president I think is grateful
that the Department of Justice is going
to have the Inspector General look into
it and determine and ensure that there
was no surveillance done for political
purposes against our campaign I think it
would be very troubling to millions of
Americans that that took place but we're
very confident and that as the Inspector
General has been doing their work
looking at the conduct of the FBI during
that period that by adding their focus
to this that we'll get to the bottom of
it because the American people have a
right to know now if there was in fact a
politically motivated attempt to take
out the Trump campaign by the Obama FBI
that is in fact worse than Watergate
remember the Watergate scandal what
involved members of the Nixon campaign
not not the government members of the
Nixon campaign who broke into the
Watergate Hotel in an attempt to get
information to bug George McGovern's
campaign in 1972 and then there was a
subsequent cover-up what we're talking
about here is the use of American
government officials to go into the
Trump campaign and destroy the Trump
campaign so it's a significantly worse
than Watergate
the accusations that are being made
right now and it's no wonder that so
many top Republican officials who
suspect that this is the case are very
upset over it and there would be
prosecutions over it and people would go
to jail over it
okay so Devin Nunez as I say the House
Intelligence Committee Chairman he comes
forward he says listen there's a red
line here okay if the DOJ or the FBI
funded a spy inside the Trump campaign
then what we're talking about is
certainly an area where people would
have to go to jail but we don't have any
documents we can't confirm whether
there's an informant or not an informant
because we've never been told or nor
given documents and in fact we've never
even asked for the name of any
informants or any sources whatsoever so
if any of that is true if they ran a spy
ring or an informant ring and they were
paying people within the Trump campaign
if any of that is true
that is an absolute redline okay and
these aren't like really serious
accusations we're not talking about the
full politicization of our law
enforcement agencies in a serious way
Jonathan Turley who's a lawyer George
Washington University he says look Trump
was pretty right when he said that he
was surveilled what I think is being a
case of willful blindness here is that
we have confirmation that Trump
apparently was correct when he said over
a year ago that he had people in his
campaign they were under surveillance
and it turns out that it was much
broader than we thought even though
people like clapper and others in the
Obama administration denied it it does
appear to be a surveillance program it
does appear to be an investigation so
that means that the serious question
here is even if the FBI was putting
informants in into the Trump campaign
the question is was the investigation
legit from the beginning this is really
the key question the key question is not
whether the FBI put an informant against
somebody in the Trump campaign the
question is was that justified now here
is the case that it was justified okay
I'm just playing devil's advocate here
here is the case that it was justified
and I think that this is not a terrible
case
okay the case that it was justified is
that George papadopolis again met with a
Russian cutout in London and then
bragged about meeting with the Russian
cutout in London's the Australian
ambassador that would be suspicious if
that had happened inside Hillary
Clinton's campaign Republicans would
have wanted the FBI to investigate okay
Donald Trump jr. had a meeting at Trump
Tower with a Russian cutout who's
promising information about Hillary
Clinton if that had been Chelsea Clinton
me
the Clinton Foundation with a Russian
proxy say made information about Trump
you would want that investigated Carter
Paige had a long-standing relationship
with the Russian government apparently
Paul Manafort had a long-standing
relationship with the Russian government
Michael Flynn the incoming national
security adviser had been paid by Russia
today which is a Russian propaganda
outlet and it sat next to Vladimir Putin
okay if any of this had happened under
Barack Obama or under Hillary Clinton
people on the right would have said that
this deserved to be investigated
so that becomes a question the question
was did the FBI have decent grounds for
looking into this stuff because the
question is not whether they used an
informant people policías informants all
the time and they use informants knowing
that people are not guilty or at least
suspecting that they might not be guilty
and people use informants to gather
information when the police launch an
investigation into someone they don't
know the person's guilty yet but they
have to investigate that's what
investigations are for that's why they
investigate if you knew somebody was
guilty no investigation is necessary but
the key question is the one Alan
Dershowitz is asking was the
investigation legit from the beginning
or was this a politically motivated hit
put out on the Trump campaign I want to
know what the evidence was no judges
found probable cause I think the
American public has to be assured that
there was a basis is not enough for
Jeffrey Toobin to say there was
collusion already at that time I want to
know what the facts were that justify
that okay and here is the bottom line in
all of this and here's why I'm
suspicious of the conservative narrative
that this was a giant conspiracy there
are two inconvenient facts and make me
suspicious that this was not a giant
collusion a giant conspiracy between
members of the FBI and the Obama DOJ to
get Trump okay piece of evidence number
one
none of this stuff broke during the
campaign if you were actually going to
target president Trump's campaign why
not break this stuff during the campaign
why not break that there were meetings
between Trump officials and low-level
Russian officials why not break the
Donald Trump jr. meeting why not let any
of this stuff leak the FBI knew about it
if this were all a conspiracy to take
down Trump why didn't break piece of
evidence number two I think is even more
damning for the for the conservative
case president Trump as I say has
plenary power over the executive branch
he has the ability to declassify any and
all of this you can declassify the
Carter page warrant the FISA warrant he
can you classify it right now today and
we can find out whether it was trumped
up
or whether there was additional material
in that FISA warrant hey we can we can
know that like now hey president Trump
can declassify all of the materials from
the FBI concerning this so-called
informant the spy inside the campaign he
can do that now why isn't he doing that
now I assume somebody has briefed him on
the material I assume somebody has told
them what's in it so if that's the case
why doesn't he just release it why does
he just release it so in just a second
I'm going to explain why President Trump
might not release it
maybe there's a decent explanation but
we'll talk about that in just a second
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at bull and branch so bull
and branch cheats these are the best
treats on the market I use them for my
children by the way like bull and branch
eats are so good it's not just for me
and my wife I bought them for my kids as
well my daughter loves her bull and bran
sheets the ones that she was sleeping
and she didn't realize how uncomfortable
they were now she complains when we're
not using bull and bran sheets on her
bed we use bull and bran sheets on our
bed as well because they are amazing
they're made from 100% organic cotton
they start out super soft and they get
even softer over time also they are
breathable sometimes you sleep under
sheets and it feels like you're just
kind of trapped under the sheet Boleyn
branch sheets they're really breathable
they're really comfortable it feels like
yours you I can't describe how good they
are until you actually try it yourself
well the good news is you can try it
yourself right now shipping is free you
can try them for 30 nights ok luxury set
of sheets can cost up to a thousand
bucks in the store bull and bran sheets
are only a couple of hundred bucks so
it's not gonna cost you an arm and a leg
again shipping is free
and you can try them for 30 nights and
if you don't love them send them back
for a refund you're not gonna want to
send them back for a refund they are
that good to get you started right now
my listeners get 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets at bull and branch com
promo club Ben that's bull and branch
comm promoted Ben go to bull and branch
calm promo code Ben for 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets also use that
promo code Ben so that they know that we
sent you so why isn't President Trump
actually releasing these these
supporting documents why doesn't he
release the FISA warrant why doesn't he
release all the information surrounding
what the FBI is doing
couple possible explanations he hasn't
been fully briefed he suspects stuff
he throws off half-cocked tweets and
then people have to come in and backfill
what he's talking about very possible
because the president is not a guy who
sits around and makes consider decisions
quite possible second possibility is
more cynical he knows what's in the
documents he doesn't actually want them
released info because if they're
released in full it undercuts his case
that he would be that he has been
targeted by the FBI and the Obama
doj possibility number three he doesn't
want to look like he's interfering too
much in the system and so instead he's
gonna call for an investigation by an
inspector general the inspector general
is independent of the Trump campaign the
Trump white house and so the Inspector
General is sort of a non-political
appointee not somebody appointed by
President Trump and that person can go
through and do the full investigation
whatever it is I assume eventually this
information will come out and then we'll
know whether or not this was a corrupt
investigation into Trump or whether
there were grounds for the investigation
into Trump one thing is certainly true
okay when the left cries foul when the
left suggests that Trump using the DOJ
to investigate these issues that that's
completely legitimate
they have no grounds to stand on here so
Adam Schiff was making this case he was
saying that the congressman from
California who lives literally lives at
the media center near the White House
and he's actually set up a pup tent
there and every morning he gets up and
he takes his thermos and he fills it
with coffee and then he goes and gets a
bowl of cereal then he sits right back
down in the pup tent until he's called
into the CNN or NBC briefing room so
chef he says this is a Saturday night
massacre in slow-motion well it
certainly looks like a Saturday night
massacre in slow-motion we have seen the
erosion of the independence of the
Justice Department which alarms me we
saw it in the lifting of the gag rule on
the witness in uranium one we saw it in
the acceleration of the investigation
against Andrew McCabe so that he could
be fired before his pension vested and
now we see it in the president or during
an investigated and investigation of his
own investigators okay so no no it's not
us that no one's being fired so if it's
a slow motion in Saturday massacre you
actually have to massacre people and
people actually have to get capped
that's not happening here the Saturday
massacre by the way was a Watergate
Massacre basically what happened is that
President Nixon wanted the Watergate
investigation to end he ordered the
special there was a special investigator
named Archibald Cox he ordered his
attorney general to fire Archibald Cox
the Attorney General refused to fire
Archibald Cox so he fired his attorney
general replaced him with Robert Bork
who then fired Archibald Cox that's what
the Saturday night massacre was none of
that has happened here he is not fired
Jeff Sessions is not fired Rosenstein
has not fired any of these people so
none of that is an evidence at all
nonetheless Democrats are very excited
Democrats are hoping that Trump makes a
big mistake here they are hoping that
President Trump doesn't use the law
enforcement methods at his disposal that
he just precipitously goes and fire
a bunch of people inside his own
administration and then they can claim
that his obstruction so here is a
congressman in Eric's wall well who says
maybe this will lead to impeachment we
can hope we can hope he's governing the
wrong country he's obstructing an
investigation into his campaign where he
is potentially a suspect the
consequences of course there are removal
from office we're not helpless here okay
so yes you are not going to be
impeaching him okay like that this is
all crazy talk but I hope the Democrats
continue to pursue the crazy talk
because it is indeed crazy Sally Yates
you'll recall was an associate attorney
she was she was the debt was the Deputy
Attorney General I believe he's the
acting Attorney General in the Russia
investigation after Jeff Sessions
recused himself and she was fired when
she refused to defend president from
travel ban in court which is not her job
she's supposed to do the bidding of the
President of the United States she does
work for the DOJ well now she's on
Morning Joe and she is claiming that the
the DOJ has been corrupted by President
Trump and she claims that Trump has
taken his assaults to a new low but you
know I think what we're seeing here is
the president has just taken his all-out
assault on the rule of law to a new
level and this time he is ordering up an
investigation of the investigators who
are examining his own campaign here's
the great irony of what she's saying
there okay so here's the great irony
that's shocking it's terrible so let's
get this straight we're supposed to
trust the investigators of President
Trump's campaign but we're not supposed
to trust the investigators of the
investigators of President Trump's
campaign because those investigators
will run by President Trump well the
first investigators were run by
President Obama
none of this washes here's the bottom
line I know this is the most unpopular
stance you can take in political and
political talk but I'm gonna make it
right now we don't know what's going on
there isn't enough evidence on any of
this we don't know whether the
conspiracy from the right is true we
don't know whether the conspiracy from
the left is true we don't know if any of
that is true here's what we do know we
do know that there have been devastating
leaks about this investigation from
members of the so-called deep State
after President Trump was elected that's
the part where I agree with the
Republican conspiracy theory there I do
think that there were members of the FBI
who are Obama holdovers who are
attempting to leak out information
members in the DOJ who are Obama
holdovers who are attempting to leak out
information now and is it possible that
the conspiracy theories about Trump's
campaign being
by Obama are true it's possible okay I'm
not gonna say it's impossible because
it's not impossible
am i suspicious that it is not true I am
suspicious I don't think the evidence
lines up in that direction at this point
in time is it also true that there was
no Russian collusion yes I have seen no
evidence that there was active Russian
collusion between the Trump campaign and
the Russian government so lots of things
can be true at one time lots of things
can be true one time one more twist that
we need to add on this particular story
and that is there have been a bunch of
stories lately regarding the possibility
that the the so-called steel dossier
that dossier that I discussed earlier
that was funded by fusion GPS which was
in turn was funded by the Hillary
Clinton campaign this would be the P
tape dossier that the reason that that
was leaked to the press it was leaked by
James clapper and members of Team Obama
to the press very very possible very
possible that it was leaked to the press
however the going theory now is that
there are a series of text messages and
emails between top members of the Obama
DOJ and the Obama FBI talking about the
possibility of the Stasi a was going to
be leaked and that this was all a setup
because in reality what was happening is
that CNN was waiting to leak the steel
dossier to reveal the steel dossier
until they had a news hook so James
Comey went to the White House informed
President Trump this became the news
hook and then CNN released the dossier
okay that's possible it is also quite
possible that CNN called up all of these
top officials about the dossier and they
knew CNN was going to break the dossier
and so then they wouldn't informed Trump
because if they'd broken the dossier
interim didn't know about the dossier
then Trump would have gotten mad at them
in other words there are a lot of
possibilities out there we don't have
the evidence for any of them that is
strong enough yet to be all outraged
about anything that has happened I'm not
outraged the Trump is investigating it
I'm not outraged about the FBI's conduct
during the campaign yet except with
regard to Hilary Clinton whom they
should have indicted
I'm not outraged about anything except
for the FBI's conduct with regard to
Hillary Clinton in 2016 which is
outrageous and the FBI's conduct after
the election the leaks that have been
coming from the DOJ and the FBI after
the election everything else I think
it's still up in the air it's still up
in the air okay meanwhile the fallout
from this awful
shooting in Texas continues 10 dead in
this terrible shooting in which a 17
year old junior at the high school
walked into the sounds of a high school
and and shot it up I will explain the
latest on that in just second first
you're gonna have to go over to Daily
wire calm and subscribe for $9.99 a
month
you can get the rest of today's show you
can also be part of our mailbag and when
we have big events when we have really
huge cool events like the ones that
we're having in Dallas and Phoenix you
have first access to VIP tickets the VIP
tickets are sold out in both places I
believe in both Phoenix and Alice if
you're not if you're not a subscriber
you can still get general admission
tickets but those are selling out really
quickly as well so you're gonna want to
do that right now go over daily wire.com
and subscribe to get all of those added
benefits plus if you get the annual
subscription you get this the very
greatest and leftist tiers hot or cold
beverage vessels it is just fantastic
$99 a year a lot cheaper than the $9.99
a month becoming an annual subscriber
and join the club people ask us all the
time how can you help the way it can
help is by subscribing it is indeed that
simple also you want to just check out
the show later for free go over to
iTunes go over to SoundCloud YouTube
please leave us a review please
subscribe we always appreciate it and go
over to Apple News and check out our
daily wire content over at Apple news
you will I think enjoy it check that out
we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so speaking of this Texas shooting 10
dead 17-year old jr. walked into the
school wearing a trench coat in 88
degree weather and was carrying a 38
pistol as well as a shotgun I believe is
the latest he got those guns from his
dad it was legal for his dad to own the
guns there's been some discussion over
whether the dad should be held legally
liable for allowing the son to get into
the the gun safe I think that's a little
bit tough it's a little bit tough when
the kid is 17 because you've taught your
kids to use the guns you want your kids
to be able to know how to defend the
house when you're not there the the
reality is that barring red flags there
are certain of these incidents they're
gonna be very difficult to prevent
unless you actually harden the barriers
around these schools I've been saying
for literally years at this point that
there should that kids at schools should
be guarded like we guard banks or like
we guard an airport okay the fact is
that there's no reason why you know I
went to a private school we had hard
barriers around our private school you
had to check in yet be buzzed into the
school and we had for us school of maybe
300 kids we had five or six different
security guards who were armed on the
school premises it seems to me this
should be the very least that we can do
for our public schools as well I promise
if you had 20 or 30 armed security for
1,500 students you'll be a lot better
than if you had four or five just
because there are too many gaps in the
security plus you actually have to have
a hard security barrier metal detectors
would be useful listen if if this sort
of stuff is going to continue to happen
we do need to guard our schools better
there's a very good piece by David
French who's good on these topics over
at National Review
in which he writes about Malcolm
Gladwell's theory that the reason that
we start with it seems like we're seeing
an uptick in school shootings right now
is because the barrier to entry for
school shootings has become so much
lower the barrier to media coverage is
lower now with each individual shooting
it looks like it's becoming more common
and so people think that it's happening
a lot even though statistically speaking
it's really not happening particularly
much 22 you know the CNN was reporting
there have been 22 school shootings this
year that's a lie there have been
something like five or six each one of
those individual tragedy and an
individual horror an individual act of
evil but the point that Gladwell is
making is the more common these things
appear to be the more common they will
become and that means that we have to do
what we can to turn these things from
happening in the first place one thing
that certainly does not help it does not
help in any way is the language that you
see thrown around in political circles
with
- these sorts of issues so Bernie
Sanders he's just awful
I heed the the socialist senator from
Vermont he says that it is unspeakable
for Congress to do nothing about gun
violence you guys have you guys done
enough in the same course not of course
not but it's like every other issue the
American people are united
overwhelmingly gun owners von gun owners
on common-sense gun safety legislation
ok you know everyone is united on all
these things except for when you get
down to the brass tacks event people are
not united on these things when people
hear gun show loophole they say where he
opposed the gun show loophole and they
here that means that every private
transaction that happens in the United
States is basically barred unless it
goes through a gun store then people
suddenly say well hold on a second I
want to give my gun to my kid why can't
I do that without going to a gun store
so here's here's part of the problem I
was on a radio show the other day in a
major metropolitan area and one of the
hosts on that particular radio show was
saying why can't Congress get things
done why don't they seem to care
why don't they care and I said well have
you ever met these legislators ever met
these legislators she said yes and I
said well did that person seem like an
evil person to you it'll really dark an
evil person and should know so what
makes you think they don't care about
dead kids there's this disconnect that
happens when we label people and we
don't actually make clear whom we are
talking about the number of people in
Congress who legitimately do not care
about school shootings I would put it
zero even people I disagree with
politically I do not think there are a
lot of people in Congress who legit
don't care about school shootings who
sit around every day they go you know
what if a hundred kids have to get shot
then fine 100 kids get shot I do not
think that that's the case I think there
are significant disagreements on policy
and these disagreements on policy are
important and have ramifications which
is why we need to talk them through but
what is not useful is creating this
broad class of people this fate this
group of faceless nameless people and
then you say well you know Congress just
doesn't care Republicans just don't care
the NRA they just don't care how many
people who say the NRA are terrorists
have ever talked to an NRA member how
many people who say that NRA members
don't care about dead kids have ever
spent time with NRA leadership and when
my friend Dana lash is talking about the
measures she thinks are useful in
preventing school violence and gun
violence at schools does anyone really
think anybody who's spent time with Dana
really think that Dana doesn't care
about kids who are getting shot on
and yet this is used as such a
convenient club and it completely
undermines and destroys our politics if
you actually believe that the people
you're talking to have no sympathy will
for you whatsoever it makes it
incredibly difficult to come to a deal
and since they're not true it's just not
true now the reason that I mentioned
this is not just because this is in the
news but because there's another story
in the news today that I think is being
completely miss covered so the the Pope
Pope Francis he apparently told the gay
man that God loves him during a private
meeting okay so this according to the UK
son in a private dialogue the pontiff is
understood to have told Juan Carlos Cruz
a victim of sexual abuse at the hands of
Catholic priests that God loves gay
people and it is fine to be homosexual
the comments are the most striking
public acceptance about homosexuality
ever made by the head of the Roman
Catholic Church the remarks were made
during a private meeting at the Vatican
between the pair in which the Pope
offered a heartfelt apology
so Cruz was a victim of a pedophile
priest named Fernando cardema Cosima's
aged 87 he was found guilty of sexual
abuse by the Vatican
in 2011 Cruz claims his suffering was
ignored by a number of Latin American
bishops who used his homosexual
homosexuality to brand him a liar when
he spoke out and then speaking to the
Spanish newspaper Cruz said the Pope
told me quote Juan Carlos that you are
gay does not matter a God made you like
this and loves you like this and I don't
care the Pope loves you like this you
have to be happy with who you are okay
so let's make clear a distinction
religious people of all stripes love gay
people okay religious Jews I know gay
people I know there are people in my
life when I'm close friends with who are
gay okay I love a lot of gay people and
what they choose to do with their own
lives from a governmental perspective is
their business does this mean that I
think that homosexual activity is not a
sin no I'm a religious Jew of course I
believe it's a sin but a religious
person including the Pope can believe
that homosexual orientation could be
implanted within you and also believe
that homosexual acts could be a sin and
still love you for who you are okay I
love that the left has attempted to say
that if you think homosexual sex is a
sin that therefore you hate gay people
these two things are not related these
two things are not related this goes
right back to that original argument
that was being made about guns which is
just because you disagree with someone
about activities that people ought to
engage in or not engage in does not mean
that these people are engaged in hate it
does not mean that these people hate you
and labeling them as haters is just
way for you to disregard their opinion
and avoid having a conversation in the
first place okay meanwhile we have to
discuss this new Starbucks policy so the
stupidity of leftism on full display in
the Starbucks policy so as you recall
there's this big blowup over at
Starbucks when it turns out that there
are these two black guys who are sitting
in a Starbucks in Philadelphia and
supposedly the manager of the Starbucks
would not give them permission to use
the bathroom and then when they would
not buy anything asked them to leave and
then when they would not leave call the
police on them and the implication was
that she was a giant racist a story I
have found hard to believe and hard to
confirm this lady according to members
of my own of my own audience who know
her is a an sjw leftist right somebody
who has chided people in the proper use
of pronouns there are several cameras in
the establishment we still have not seen
full tape of what happened that
Philadelphia establishment well thanks
to the outrage over that supposed a
system end again this is weird because
there are actual some there are actual
racist events that have taken place in
the United States you don't hear about
those because when everybody recognizes
something is racist the media has
nothing to talk about the media
purposefully pick instances where
there's a plausible story that nothing
racist happened and then they use these
as flash points that if you don't
immediately bend the narrative they wish
to purvey then this means that you don't
take racism seriously enough in any case
Starbucks reacted to the Philadelphia
story by telling everybody that they had
to get retrained on implicit bias which
is just sheer nonsense and then they
changed their policy okay they changed
their policy and their policy was that
anyone who came into a Starbucks could
now use the restroom the problem was
that there are Starbucks on every corner
and lots of homeless people go into
Starbucks and they go into the bathrooms
and there they proceeded to set up shop
or do drugs so what did Starbucks have
to do well now they have to clarify
their policy toward non paying guests
the Seattle based retailer on Saturday
this is according to The Wall Street
Journal and said it would allow all
guests in its US company owned stores to
use its cafes including its restrooms
whether or not they make a purchase
again this would be idiotic policy if
you just allow people to sit down in
your chairs and sit there all day how in
the world are you actually in a sell
anything at Starbucks
then announcement which attracted some
support also drew complaints the cafes
would not have enough seats for paying
customers and would turn into homeless
shelters and drug havens this is
certainly true in Seattle which has
experienced a massive upsurge in the
number of homeless people in the city
well on Monday
Starbucks revealed more about the policy
they told The Wall Street
that employees now have detailed
instructions on what to do if someone is
behaving in a disruptive manner such as
smoking using drugs or alcohol using
restrooms improperly or sleeping at
issue in essence is whether Starbucks
views itself as a business that caters
to customers or a quasi public place
generally welcome to all yeah this
idiotic of course they are a business
catering to customers they could not
make any money if they were a quasi
public business welcome public place
generally welcome to all people would
set up shop and they would continue to
occupy all of the tables so other
restrooms and retailers also must manage
the issue of lingering customers and non
paying guests Starbucks has promoted
itself as providing a third place
between home and work where people can
freely exchange ideas
it essentially pioneered the idea that
is now generating controversies
McDonald's Panera Bread they now offer
free Wi-Fi they encourage customers to
linger Panera didn't respond to a
request for comment this is all true but
if you sit there for too long without
buying some of them I've known for years
like I've worked from many coffee shops
over my years because I always work from
the laptop well I know going in that you
are supposed to walk up to the counter
and buy a thing right who-who doesn't
know that everybody knows you're
supposed to do this but now Starbucks
has changed its policy in response to
the stupidity of political correctness
and it is indeed highly stupid
businesses cannot operate so long as
they make political correctness their
first priority and it's amazing to watch
all these social justice warrior led
companies that built themselves on the
basis of free-market capitalism and a
willingness to do business with
customers now try to shift their policy
because they want to appear kinder and
gentler to the public you saw the same
thing over at Google with James d'amour
right James d'amour said well maybe the
reason there aren't enough female
engineers here is because you haven't
created a conducive work environment
with cooperative tasks and also because
there are fewer women who are applying
in stem cells in STEM jobs note stem
cells and stem jobs right there are
fewer women who are applying in science
technology engineering and math because
there are fewer women who have a
predilection to go into those jobs and
also because what the bell curve tends
to show with regard to performance in
sciences and math is that women tend to
be closer to the center of the bell
curve men tend to be at the tail so many
that are really bad at math or really
good at math and that means that when
you go up to the upper level there are
more men than women on a proportional
basis James d'amour his memo prompted
his firing and then Google put out a
memo suggesting to all of its managers
that things like meritocracy where white
were white constructs
well if Google had
that premise google would not be a
billion a multi-billion dollar company
obviously it's may all the things that
made business is successful they're not
willing to dump on the side of the road
in order to make nice with the press and
politically correct idiocy the good news
there i guess is that new capitalist
businesses that don't abide by by the
politically correct idiocy will now be
able to make their way in the
marketplace if starbucks gonna be dumb
there'll be other coffee shops that rise
to the occasion
okay time for some things i like and
then some things that I hate so things
that I like over Chevy Volt which is the
Jewish celebration of the giving of the
Torah at Sinai I was able to do a lot of
reading I spoke at a school recently
that was a Habad school about or the for
people who don't know about you've seen
Ichabod about are the people corn of
lightning menorahs and in public areas
they're the people who are offering to
they ask you if you're Jewish and then
if you are Jewish then they will rap to
fill in on you to fill in are the
phylacteries that you wear on your arm
and on your head if you're an Orthodox
Jew and that movement but the Lubavitch
movement was led by what is known as the
Rebbe the Rebbe was Rob Menachem Mendel
Schneerson and the Schneerson died in
1994 is very good biography of him by
Joseph's solution solution is co-written
a bunch of books with Dennis Prager my
friend and this book is really
entertaining it's really good and it is
a portrait of a person who is who was
fully devoted to the care of other human
beings he worked not only in st. hours
but he met with an enormous number of
people ranging from politicians to just
normal folks he used to meet with people
every night pretty much from like 10:00
p.m. to 2:00 a.m. on like a 10 minute
rotating basis and try and have talks
with them about how to improve their
lives the religion can be an awful force
for good it can be an awful force or it
can be a good force and the Rebbe made
religion a very good force in a number
of ways you should read his biography
it's worth it's well worth reading it's
just a leadership guide for anyone
Joseph's solutions book I'm an author
Mendel Schneerson check it out Rebbe
it's called Rebbe okay so time for a
thing that I hate
all righty so the thing that I hate
today this is another manufactured
stupid controversy so Kendrick Lamar who
is apparently a rapper of some sort
demonstrating my full knowledge of the
pop cultural range I believe he's a
rapper
so Kendrick Lamar had he was doing a
concert and he invited a fan onstage to
sing and then he asked the fan who's a
white woman to sing the lyrics of his
song mad city which is maad city which
is not his pal mad but sure okay and
then she one of the lyrics in here uses
the n-word okay here's the video of what
it looked like
[Music]
[Applause]
do the rules a little bit it's really
cool bro you have to work you got to
read one single word though oh I'm sorry
yeah you did I'm so sorry
oh she say okay yeah
okay I mean just what the hell's wrong
with this guy like he knows what the
lyrics to his own song are that is not
her fault I'm sorry that is not the
fault with a white lady who gets up
there he's not like he said to her
beforehand you know go easy on the
lyrics to my song you wrote them there
dude
you don't want somebody actually reading
the lyrics of your song or doing the
lyrics to your song don't write the
lyrics in there or ask the lady up if
you've got a problem with a white lady
rapping your song as you wrote it then
maybe you should have invited a black
lady up there to wrap your song as your
own she's got plenty of black fans there
it's just it's absurd okay and I think
people caught on to it so a lot of folks
on on Twitter were like this is just a
setup right the day they brought a fan
up to sing and then flipped when she
said the n-word and he knew what he was
doing this woman's life is gonna be
ruined on social media now she's gonna
be claimed to be a racist when she just
wanted to go to a concert and sing
presumably with someone she was a fan of
it's it's just it's just ridiculous
Lamar was evidently under the impression
that Delaney would sense her a skip and
sends herself and skip the racial
epithet in the song but she clearly did
not get the memo and then said Delaney
who is that this this woman who was
called out of the crowd should man down
where are you from n-word F who you know
where you from my n-word what your
grandma say huh my n-word okay so it's
not like this appears one time in the
song if there's 1,000 times in the song
like what she's supposed to do okay get
up here and sing the song and she goes
literal this is what it would sound like
man town where are you from F who you
know where are you from where your
grandma stay hum I get like you wrote
the lyric dude this is your own fault
you don't want people using the n-word
then don't use the n-word
don't use the n-word in your song okay I
understand that there are distinctions
between black people using the n-word
and white people using the n-word and
that there's a whole attempt by certain
members of the black community to
co-op's the the term n-word and then use
it as a way of empowerment I think this
is fully stupid okay I think it's stupid
I'm just gonna be honest with this there
are there are lots of slurs that are
used against Jews all the time okay and
you've heard me try to co-op the Jewish
jokes okay but you've never heard me
tried to co-opt the K word right there's
a K word that has been used against Jews
for many many many many decades
okay Jews don't call each other my bleep
okay they don't call each other that
because why would you want to promulgate
the word if the word is bad the word is
bad especially to avoid situations just
like
because it sets up this ridiculous
double standard I don't think it is
worthwhile to have that lyric in the
song but if you are gonna have that
lyric in the song you can't be surprised
when people sing your song
the whole point of you singing the song
is that others will sing your song oh
Kendrick Lamar ah how I mourn for you
okay well we'll be back here tomorrow
with all of the latest on everything
under the Sun and Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah al Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018